quality of life is not just about how
much money you make or how much money
you have to spend on parks when quality
of life is how people feel about their
community hi I'm Alexis Garcia with
Reason TV here at the Atlantic City web
conference in Los Angeles and right now
I'm joined by Dan walling he is the
mayor of Flint Michigan so mayor Hualien
you know we've kind of seen the plight
that's befallen Detroit can you talk a
little bit about what's happened in your
town yeah Flint to Detroit very similar
dynamics we're going through a
generational change the restructuring of
the global automotive industry the
change in family's preferences for
housing and shopping and how our
communities that boomed in the earlier
part of the 20th century aren't well
designed for the 21st century economy
for expectations of the 21st century
neighborhood or shopping and commercial
districts so we're having to look at our
entire community all 33 square miles and
figure out how every one of those places
can be vibrant and valuable in the 21st
century I found it interesting because I
heard you speak before and the statistic
about almost a little over 30% of the
space in your town is brownfields or you
know unused commercial Lots or abandoned
homes what are you guys kind of looking
at to put that to use yeah it's it's a
huge challenge and it's vacant
commercial property vacant residential
property old school buildings they're no
longer used that are now closed so we we
have this vacant property all across the
city
but when we were at the peak the city of
Flint was really overstuffed I mean
there were people living on top of
people for all the jobs available at the
General Motors factories so it's not
necessarily a bad thing when we look at
our long term prospects to have some
room in the city where we can expand our
green space along the Flint River we can
create larger educational campuses even
in our neighborhoods to be able to offer
more than a small house on a 40-foot lot
to be able to offer a developer an
opportunity to build a larger home on a
larger lot so
we're having to rethink the patterns of
our neighborhoods and our business
districts and our college and university
campuses but this vacant property does
give us a real opportunity to design our
city for the 21st century
now speaking of design you and some
other city leaders have put together
kind of a plan I think it's the imagined
Flint plain kind of looking forward and
when you were going through that you
kind of realized that some of these
zoning codes don't really fit that plan
can you talk a little bit about the
reform that you're looking at there yeah
we have a new master plan that's adapted
in we're revising our zoning code
because all of this was really designed
for the 1950s and the 1960s the big
production economy the single use
neighborhood the separated commercial
shopping districts that were all auto
oriented well here today in the 21st
century those dynamics have changed we
want mixed-use environments where you
can live work learn play you can walk
you can get on a bus so that means our
roads need to go on diets make room for
bikes and for buses and pedestrians it
means that our zoning needs to allow a
small let's say manufacturer not a not a
dirty old industrial facility but a new
manufacturer that's designing clothes or
a small electrical part in a supply
chain that can be done in a commercial
district with loft living upstairs in
the building next to the college or the
university so those are the kind of
innovative places that we're trying to
create in our new zoning code we're
thinking about place making not
separating uses but bringing uses
together and doing that in a very
extreme sense of the word where we're
not only having housing and shopping
which is normally what you think of with
mixed-use we think of extreme mixed use
of housing shopping learning playing in
parks and also the productive aspect of
of manufacturing which is something our
city's been known for for a long time
this is now just a new generation of
manufacturing we had carriages we had
cars now we're involved in diverse 21st
century advanced manufacturing with
medical devices and electrical
components and supplies for the auto
industry and transportation and
distribution companies that are beyond
just automobiles were part all that in
Flint that's sort of diversifying right
and do you see that you know the City
Council and the residents they're kind
of open to kind of tackling some of
these outdated laws yeah we have our
differences but the amazing thing about
this two-year process we went through to
envision a new future was it ended with
a plan that was able to be adopted
unanimously by our Planning Commission
and our City Council and that really
told me we have districts for our
council and our planning tells me that
people all across the city really saw
the benefit of this new vision and we're
using it to attract new investments and
to better use our existing federal
resources and also to get volunteers
involved because people want to be a
part of making these positive changes
they didn't know where to start
this framework now shows citizens and
community groups and black clubs how
they can be involved in moving the
community forward as part of a bigger
effort when you take office do you kind
of went to I think there's nine
different one yeah and you know you
really engaged the neighborhoods I think
you've seen in kind of our series
looking out Detroit where some of these
you know private citizens and private
groups kind of stepped in what have you
seen in Flint you know citizens stepping
in to deal with some of these things
like neighborhood blight there's some
incredible successes and it's rethinking
City Hall just like we've had to rethink
our economy and rethink our
neighborhoods the idea that government
is going to provide all of these
programs government has to be a partner
and has to facilitate the planning and
and the organizational infrastructure
but then it's it's citizen groups its
churches its schools and businesses that
are really the ones who are refining the
plans making sure what we're doing is
appropriate in each area and then
providing the the real people power to
actually get the work done to adopt the
park and turn it into a Youth Center
with a partnership with the Boys and
Girls Club in the old days in Flint that
would have been a city of Flint Parks
and Rec program now it's the city of
Flint with a Memorandum of Understanding
with
KREM Fitness Foundation and the Boys &
Girls Club and a series of neighborhood
groups working through keep Genesee
County beautiful to actually get out
every couple weeks and and do the work
in the park to make it the kind of
facility that we want for our families I
think you see like a lot of these cities
are you know filling the squeeze
fiscally do you see that as a model
going forward that you know the the city
structure is gonna be kind of where some
of the organization takes place but it's
really gonna be a partnership with
community groups yeah I think it has to
be and and when we went out and tested
that and talked about it with our
community it wasn't just the sense that
well government has less money so we're
gonna have to rely on citizens community
groups and citizens we're really saying
no as a as a first option we want this
to be a partnership now if you go and
get some more money then that's a good
thing for all of us we want that
government resource but we want to be in
the driver's seat we want to be a part
of this plan and implementing it in our
neighborhood in our business corridor so
even as we recover economically and
build our tax base back our citizens
really demanded that they're at the top
of every one of our strategies dealing
with blight dealing with Public Safety
being more involved in education it's
got to be citizens and families first
yeah because they live there so they
would have a better idea of what needs
to be done then you know some bureaucrat
in DC right that's right and that's what
creates the real quality of life you
know quality of life is not just about
how much money you make or how much
money you have to spend on parks or in
quality of life is how people feel about
their community and the more they're
involved in shaping the plans and then
doing the work and seeing others you
know support them then that that's a
completely better and higher quality of
life than maybe a program that looks
really pretty and has a lot of money but
has never really connected with the
citizens so we've been forced to learn
those hard lessons in Flint but I think
it's a good foundation for us to move
forward from for mayor well and thank
you so much for joining us today
you're welcome Thanks and for reason TV
I'm Alexis Garcia